un militant
volontaire il est calme calme dynamique
quelqu'un au service des
autres Thierry grimaau donc je suis
délégué départemental de l'USP et de
lufolp à ce jour mon action et ma
passion c'est de faire pratiquer du
sport mais comme un moyen
d'éducation bienvenue dans les haut de
Saint-Leu à la maison donc un petit peu
sur les
hauteurs ce qu'on a éclairireur de
France et il est important de noter
puisque c'est le mou mouement SCO Laï et
je suis dans cette mouvance de laïcité
c'est quelque chose de primordial pour
moi j'aime bien j'aime monter des
projets alors on me dit quelque foois
oui mais tu es dég depuis pas mal
d'années à Laur tu tu devrais changer
mais je pense qu'il y a eu des
évolutions dans ma fonction cesvolutions
font que maintenant je trouve toujours
un intérêt bon il s'engage dans plein de
d'activités mais en fait il aime ce
qu'il fait alors on pourra pas lui
interdire de faire ce qu'il aime parce
que de toute façon si c'est pas avoir un
bonhomme que est mal dans sa peau c'est
pas la peine bon Naomi dépêche-toi on va
bientôt
partir il est calme du tout jamais SP
jamais malgré tout ce qu'il fait là oui
après il se débrouille pour tout faire
en une journée être à l'heure avoir un
bon timing donc c'est j'arrive pas trop
à comprendre avec lui qui m'impressionne
un peu ton téléphone il est rangé et tu
le mets en pause que quand tu es en
arrêt en pause tu mets ton téléphone tu
écoutes mais pas dans le boulot hein ah
c'est la jeune jeune tu fais ton job de
papa bah écoute il faut assumer mon
boulot c'est de former les jeunes à la
responsabilisation je pense qu'il
faudrait aussi commencer par ses propres
enfants parce que quelque fois on les
oublie on fait quand même des activités
ensemble déj fait du sport avec sa fille
qui est encore à la maison il voit son
fils donc loloé qui est sur l'USP
également qui travaille avec nous et
puis bon on se ménage un petit peu de
temps pour nous prochaine étap les
avirons St des
abirons c'était un jeune qui quitté
l'école normale qui est qui a atterri à
Saint-Leu où à l'époque moi j'ai j'étais
délégué USP de circonscription ce sont
des gens qui ne comptent pas leur temps
nous notre objectif c'est vraiment
responsabiliser les enfants par des
pratiques sportives on n'est pas dans un
champ de compétition de classement de
sélection ce qui fait que comme je dis
toujours lorsque je rencontre un
journaliste il me dit vous mais on sait
pas trop où vous mettre est-ce que vous
êtes à l'éducation est-ce que vous êtes
à la culture l'animation de la ville ou
bien en sport et comme on n pas un
calendrier avec championnat avec des
résultats ben ça fait pas vendre et
pourtant à la Réunion regroupe 22000
adhérents ce qui est quand même la deè
fédération sportive après la Ligue de
foot
Martine il croit en ce qu'il fait il a
la foi il veut c'est une façon pour lui
de faire changer les choses il pense que
vraiment euh tout passe par l'éducation
et passe par le sport il a pas un ég de
mesur il cherche pas à ramener à lui
c'est pas l'individu lui qui l'intéresse
lui en tant que président d'un projet
voilà que soit le Koji ou luusp ou
lufolp on est dans un fonctionnement qui
doit être ouvert à tout le monde la
preuve dès qu'il y a un problème on dit
ah c'est l'école qui n'a pas fait ça ou
bien s'il manque des sportifs on n'est
pas champion du monde ou bien on n pas
on n pas de champion olympique en France
ah ben c'est l'école qui a pas fait du
sport pourtant on le fait on le pratique
mais après un moment donné je pense
qu'il y a une cassure le lien qui manque
entre les clubs et
nousette et ben on prépare l'assemblée
générale du Koji on doit rendre compte
un peu et puis rencontrer les les sur
les la manifestation à venir
savoir non on tourne on tourne d' le
côtéci c'est vrai que dans les Jeux des
îles je suis passé sur différents stads
j'ai été adjoint à la délégation réunion
au céchel ensuite j'ai été chef de la
délégation 98 à la Réunion j'étais
membre du kig et là quelque part je
passe de l'autre côté je suis dans
l'organisation donc j'aurais un peu vu
tous les tous les champ d'intervention
sur les Jeux des îles on a tous engagé
notre responsabilité collective pour la
Réunion là ouais donc c'est cette
responsabilité collective on va
l'assumer et aour de TI il y a les jeux
mais le Koji mais il y a aussi le cross
il y a tout le mouvement sportif où on a
besoin des gens comme Thierry et ces
bénévoles sont de plus en plus
rareir j'aimerais que la solidarité
rayonnaise continue bah qu'il
réussissent déjà les l'organisation des
Jeux des îles et puis qui reste comme il
est fidèle à lui-même ben qu'il prenne
sa retraite il est trop dans la sociatif
faut arrêter il fera différemment ben on
reste toujours un TER d'exemple les G
des on a placé comme terre d'un champion
mais également d'accueil et je pense
qu'il faut que la Réunion reste une
terre
d'accueil